three people died that night at Princess  Diana dodiel fired and a man caught  Henry Paul who was the driver Dodie Al  fired hit the back of Henry Paul's seat  with a weight of about four elephants  and so he hit the back of the seat and  completely crashed on report against the  steering wheel Trevor Reese Jones had  his seat belt on and so when Diana who  wasn't wearing a seat belt hit him she  was partially  protected by him when we look up the  injuries that Diana had they were very  minor injuries in her left lung the  injury that she had  was one of these hidden injuries  she was okay she was chatting she I  think she had a broken arm it was only  on the journey to hospital  that her condition tipped from being  increasingly unstable to sirius and she  had a cardiac arrest but if only she'd  worn a seatbelt she would I'm sure still  be alive today